[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes with me your host for this week
Katie balls coming up on the show
Rishi Cena became the new prime minister
this week the third Tory Digger this
year Jane's Forsyth looks at the
challenges through neck will face this
winter in the Magazine's cover piece and
he'll join me alongside Anthony Selden
CNAC will be the UK's first Hindu prime
minister what does his religion say
about his character
I'll speak to Samir Shah
language driver writes her column this
week on The Hangover of economic
emergencies why do we expect interest
rates to always be low she'll join me
along with Hamish McRae
Louise Paris is the future of feminism
is conservative why she'll be on spec TV
alongside Judy bindle to explain
and finally while this trust's
government was in free fall a diary
editor James here was hastily doing
rewrites to his biography of her he'll
be on to chat about the agony of writing
that book out of the blue
if you enjoy spectator TV why not
subscribe to our YouTube channel
click the red subscribe button at the
bottom of the screen and never miss an
episode again just tap the Bell icon
first up Rishi C note became prime
minister this week the third this year
our political editor James Forsyth
writes in our cover piece that the new
prime minister has an unenviable list of
problems to deal with from the economy
to the NHS to Simply the Tory party
to discuss them James joins me now
alongside the historian and author
Anthony Selden
James Anthony thanks for joining
spectator TV this week James Hugh Wright
in The Spectator cover piece about the
various challenges awaiting Rishi sunak
so let's uh go through those and start
with the economy which you argue is the
reason he is now prime minister
yes I think I think on September 5th
when Liz truss won the Tory leadership
you know it was going to take something
pretty dramatic to turn things around
and that dramatic thing was the market
reaction to the mini budget the richest
United economic warnings from the summer
being Vindicated and I mean that is why
he has ended up as prime minister but it
also means that he Now deals to deal
with that situation which is going to be
difficult I think they're sensibly
hearing Jeremy Hunter push back uh the
Autumn statement into November to give
themselves a bit more time to look at
things and the markets do appear calmer
I mean I think it is striking to me that
that pushing back the statement from
October the 31st to November the 17th
has not elicited some great negative
Market reaction
and I mean that suggests that the kind
of hot breadth of the market is off the
UK government's neck and it has a little
bit more time to think about that but
that doesn't mean that you still haven't
got very very difficult decisions coming
down the track and decisions that I
think will Define the rest of us
Parliament
Anthony we're now on to the third Tory
leader this year do you think that Rishi
c-neck is uh potentially going to bring
a period of calm after so much turmoil
or is that too big an Ask of anyone
I think it's going to be a very
difficult for Richie sunac at the very
least he needs to get through this
winter which will be the most difficult
winter for over 40 years since uh the
winter of
1978-79
and could be more difficult because
they're a health crises on top of the
economic and the industrial uh unrest
and the financial and the international
crises
um many of those factors are outside the
government's control
so just getting through to the spring uh
with a sense of competence a sense of
calm with the markets in the right place
uh holding the party together
um which Casey you were talking about
which he's fulfilled unlike his trusts
in his choice of government and a
broad-based government
but creating such a government as you
say is different to actually holding it
together when they're difficult
decisions about defense spending about
health spending about overseas
development and if you can hold the
government together without resignations
without histrionics if he can show
confidence through the very bumpy ride
over the next four months
he then will give himself
some Headroom but I don't think he's
going to be able to do very much look uh
uh late serving governments whether Alec
Douglas human 1963 to 64 or Gordon Brown
2007 to 10 uh or John major before him
uh they really don't go down in history
as achieving very much unless they
happen to have a crisis like Gordon
Brown had the Good Fortune to have a
crisis on his watch the global financial
crisis which he had some Acumen over and
that's what he's remembered for rather
than domestic reforms and Innovations so
if sunap wants to do that he should
limit it to just one or two areas such
as education
which absolutely needs
um a government Focus after six seven
changes of education secretary and it
needs to to have a steady hand driving
that forward that could be something but
he will be remembered as a late serving
uh Tory Minister who if he does
Australia well will minimize the size of
the labor landslide in 2024 if indeed he
gets that far unless events really turn
in his favor
uh obviously a Tory Victory is not out
of the question
James when we look at that cabinet and
as we just heard it's very broad there's
clearly been an effort to try and make
it unifying with MPS and different wings
of the party in it but is the risk of
this
um that ultimately if there are
difficult decisions come to fiscal event
um in terms of some cuts and also just
policy Direction
um Richie said it's quite vulnerable to
resignations from people who won't like
one thing he does
yeah I mean the the fundamental question
is does the Tory party realize that it
needs to pull together or hang
separately which is essentially the
choice facing it you know there are two
ways you can look at the opinion polls
for the Tories right now one is that
this is an existential crisis for them
and that if they don't unite and rally
around the leader then they are they are
they they risk a kind of Wipeout style
event or the danger is that they look at
it and say oh look we're going to lose
the next election anyway so we might as
well position ourselves for a future
contest or uh or have these arguments
now because they're what matters I think
the the interesting thing is that
in this kind of broad-based cabinet you
know that is clearly a message from the
leadership saying look you know we get
that we need to create an internal
Coalition here I I think we wait to see
how the party responds I think the
initial signs have been relatively
positive
um I think it's striking how uh and we
are and let let us be frank Casey but we
are only you know less than 72 hours in
but they have been remarkably few noises
off so far
yeah and when I think we're looking
ahead to where the cuts might be James
where where do you think that they could
fall in terms of that fiscal event where
do you think when when it comes to the
size of that black hole which are now uh
closer to 35 40 billion what kind of
measures are going to be taken to Philip
I think that I think the big question is
what what is the balance between tax
Rises and spending restraint how much
can you do by just trying to keep
spending uh flat in real terms in the in
the in the final years of the forecast
period I think the good news for them is
uh one thing by by that by their own
actions they benefited from which is
these government debt servicing costs
are coming down steadily because the
kind of sunac hunt uh Scenic enhance
presence is reassuring the markets the
other thing is how fast at the moment
gas prices are falling in Europe which
obviously matters because the government
is so exposed to the gas price because
of its decision to to offer this kind of
universal energy subsidy this winter
and then you mentioned how hard it would
be for uh the Tories to win a fifth term
but of course nothing is impossible um
in British Politics as we've seen over
the past few years
um are there any former Prime Ministers
that you think Richard can take
inspiration from when it comes to
Turning you know a disunited party uh
you know around and turning the fortunes
so uh well uniquely he has uh five Tory
uh Prime Ministers still alive uh any of
whom he could use uh in some uh way or
other uh uh internationally probably to
advance his cause one in particular uh
is going to cause him trouble as you're
both acutely aware
um and that's Boris Johnson where he to
show some leg uh which he might well do
to tempt
um to tempt tourists with wandering eyes
uh as soon as Rishi sunak falls into
trouble I suspect
um that uh the future is going to depend
upon factors outside which you see next
uh control
um particularly fuel prices and what
happens in Ukraine and what happens uh
this winter with Hells
um
and Katie announces that question late
creating Prime Ministers isn't a
phenomenon that we've seen uh much of if
at all in British politics Prime
Ministers tend to if they have ideas not
all of them
um astonishingly
um once elected come up with many ideas
at all some of them rather baffle to
find ideas uh David Cameron for example
he wanted to be a prime minister he
thought he'd be rather good at it
but he didn't have a burning passion
unlike Margaret's hatchard you wanted to
see implemented neither did Gordon Brown
very oddly when he took over in 2007 so
if they have those burning ideas at all
not all do they tend to deliver them at
the very beginning of their Premiership
so I I'm stuck
which in Casey because I don't think uh
that their history is a good guide I'm
prepared ready to be stand corrected uh
for
um Prime Ministers who late in the day
have provided a new Direction and a new
sense of regeneration which exactly is
what the party needs uh to unite around
a common cause as James is saying that's
going to be extremely difficult uh
because what is it that does unite them
other than a sense of a common enemy uh
it's extraordinarily bad luck that
Jeremy corbyn has departed this scene uh
and the far more plausible if
okay very dull
keastarma has taken over because he is
less frightening
um Scotland and the threat of the
dismemberment of the 1603 1707 Union
Scotland could be perhaps a cause of one
call Wars amongst others but the tour is
always better when they're uniting
behind common cause and in their
self-interest just as a quick footnote
the party will not disappear some people
Peter o'born and and many others have
suggested it will the Tory party will
never disappear uh the last thing
standing on Earth in the universe will
be the Tory party the last thing finally
to disappear into the Easter because of
its uh profound uh Instinct uh for
survival and it's Readiness to jettison
anything to maintain its own existence
it's a true uh darwinian champion on the
political scene as we have seen in the
swiftness of icing uh one leader after
six weeks
um James just just on that point of
survival and ultimately racism suggested
to MPS he doesn't want to have an early
election but there are lots of people
who are watching what's going on and
saying he doesn't have a mandate he
wasn't eating bit by Tory members let
alone the public and how long can he
really hold this this United party
together what do you think is going to
be the answer here because you speak to
some figures and they think if he can
get to the end of 2023 without having an
election Richard will have been doing
well um in terms of his party
so my instinct is the election is going
to be in 2024 and relatively late and I
think that will hold because I I think
that you know you need the only way you
could have an early election is if 35
Tory MPS or so decided to vote for it
and I find it hard to believe that you
will find 35 Tory MPS prepared to vote
for it because they would be consigning
uh so many of their colleagues to almost
certain defeat if you don't have time
for uh inflation to get through the
system time for uh soon act to set out
his platform so I I think I think the
Tory party will be able to hold together
to the extent of of not going for an
early election I mean the challenge is
whether they can show that they've got a
kind of governing agenda at the same
time which I think they are which is you
know obviously something that they need
to set out in the in the coming in the
coming weeks and months but I I don't I
don't sense that there is any appetite
on the Tory side for any action I think
that you know I thought it was very I
thought it was very striking that that
Russia now in that speech outside
Downing Street said look you know I'm
going to explain to you why I'm standing
here and then talked about how the
Mandate of the 2019 Tory Manifesto you
know is not the property of just one
person but belongs to all Tory MPS which
you know you could you could the subtext
of that was clear
and Anthony just finally um when it
comes to the reshuffle we've been
discussing I think one of the more
controversial perhaps the most
controversial appointment was to return
is to add a braveman to the home office
now this is just six days after she was
forced to resign over a security breach
involving a personal email and a
sensitive document that went to the nmp
and we've spoken out before I think on
spectator TV about ethics and standards
and I think with Richard Scenic there
was a sense that he was going to be a
man of integrity and he's pushed that
idea that he's different than what came
before do you think this weakens his
message
mentally for one moment think that she
would have been his Preferred Choice as
Home Secretary but it was necessary uh
as is uh Rob to shore up at the right
wing uh and he has to hold the party
together even if it means compromising
on uh and raising embarrassing questions
that will continue to be asked about her
uh ethically and the last thing that he
wants uh is uh that stench of uh of of
of impropriety that dog the the
conservatives in from 1961 onwards until
they fell in 19
at 64 and dug the last days of the last
unbroken period of conservative
government from
1994 onwards with Back to Basics uh and
a whole series of ethical questions he's
going to want desperately to get that
off the agenda if he can but he's
trapped and and that's what happens in
late serving governments you don't have
the freedom that you do if you're the
prime minister at the beginning
everything is trade-offs everything that
he will be having to do will be
trade-offs so it just comes back to the
best you can hope for apart from luck
um or internationally and and
financially
um and health uh is to get through uh
this winter with maximum competence and
then do one or two or possibly three
things possibly education uh for which
he can be remembered
um which might stand if something
terrible happens to labor it would
maximize the chance of a Tory victory in
2024 I totally agree with James that
it's it's going to be then I mean why on
Earth would Tory MPS be so stupid no
guarantee that they won't be uh but why
would they be to call an election before
thank you Anthony thank you James
Richard will be the UK's first Hindu
prime minister
in this week's magazine Samir Shah
wonders how students religion will
inform his Premiership
Smith joins me now to explain
Samir thanks for coming on spectator TV
today you write in the streets magazine
about Rishi sunax religion of Hinduism
what do we need to know in terms of how
this could affect uh how he is as prime
minister
well Hinduism is a pretty uh difficult
religion to get your hold on get a hold
on it's quite slippery really can be all
things to all people so it's quite
difficult to Define exactly what
particular version of Hinduism that
Rishi Embraces to establish how it might
impact on how Rishi develops his
policies I mean I think that uh there
are a few Clues and my view is that um
uh Hinduism is one of the things that I
think he's very keen on is education
education is what um
pulled him up on his parents like many
Indian families sacrificed a great deal
to put him through a good school and I
think education would be a big policy uh
imperative for him he's already spoken
about that uh the idea of a British
Baccalaureate and uh using AI in
classroom so I can see he's already
beginning to think about how to improve
education for for people all over
England
and he also write the Hinduism is not a
pacifist religion why is that important
well I think I think it's because I
think it was important to tell people
because people do have a view of
Hinduism as a kind of peace and love and
all that kind of stuff slightly affected
by our view of Mahatma Gandhi and those
of us of a certain age will remember the
60s and the Beatles and George Harrison
and the Maori shame it was all about
love and peace so there's a there's a
view abroad to Hinduism is is a peace
loving religion I think it needs to be
made clear that Hinduism isn't
it's just as violent as other religions
are and and Hindus and indeed we could
all remember can we not in the doing
partition Hinduism
you know there was a lot of killing
going on there so it was important to
realize that
that Richie sunak's view of global
politics is not going to be driven by
some uh somewhat uh
wrong-headed view of what it is to be a
Hindu he's not gonna he's not going to
take a view about global politics and
the fight against Russia or China or
indeed of course what's going on in
Ukraine with some kind of pacifist
approach
and what are the religious practices of
a Hindu um that that will you know shape
recency next days and weeks
well I mean again because it's you know
don't forget Hinduism has a thousand
Gods probably more in fact you know the
people I don't know the exact number and
depending on which God you choose
you can have religious practice to to
worship that God I'm not sure which
particular God and that Rishi sunaka
worship worships I mean you will all be
familiar and uh readers and Spectators
and viewers of this we're Familiar of
the elephant god Ganesh uh that's a very
popular god
um and lots of Hindus celebrate and
worship Ganesh and what that means is
that you have a little uh image of
Ganesh somewhere in your house and you
Garland it and every morning you might
say a little prayer to it uh so you pick
your own God you stick this God in some
uh part of your house and you said daily
prayer
um the actual rituals that most Hindus
follow and we know that Rishi follows
this and that's Diwali very recently of
course and that's the it's the Festival
of Lights and lots of Hindus and my
family did uh you know because my mother
was a Hindu you put out little lights
all over the house and also on the on
the doorsteps and and
you also do some decorations with the
powder that's a very familiar uh ritual
that most Hindus practice another one
that they do is known as rakshabandan
and that takes place in August and
that's the kind of commitment of
Brothers to their sisters and sisters to
their brothers and you'll always see
Hindu men wandering around with a little
red thing around their wrist and that's
about that's when a sister ties That
to her brother and uh that shows her
Everlasting Love by the sister to the
brother and the brothers Everlasting
commitment to protect and
protect her so that's another familiar
ritual
and just before yesterday talk about
more religion as prime minister I just
wanted
um as you as you explain there's no such
you know one set of beliefs a Hindu
would have or or God
um but is there such a such a thing as
universal Hindu values
up to point
um Katie that the the fact is there is
no
book there is no reveal word there is no
prescription and you can really pick and
choose the kind of life you want to lead
the universal values such as they are
uh in some sense predictable and uh and
are common to many religions which is a
sense of Duty a sense of looking after
your family looking after it uh so
that's all part of it be honest and duty
is an important value that I think
Hinduism has but one of the things that
I say in my article is that another
value of Hinduism has which I think
might surprise many is um a real license
to make money you know making money is a
is a completely okay for Hinduism it's
not it's uh no you don't have to but
it's a perfectly good thing to make
money and I think that's rather
interesting that's not really a value
but it's a way of life I mean I would
say Hinduism as much a way of life and a
culture as it is a theology
and to be fair the sunac family
um have taken making money
pretty well
I think what's interesting is that
throughout India extremely wealthy
families uh
really put a lot of money into temples
I mean they really do temples are very
wealthy in India uh because Rich
families do that and it's partly to
secure the wealth you know to make sure
they've got things favorably of you that
you are doing good things you are
providing money for a temple so that it
has it's it looks good and it's updated
and all that so you do find extremely uh
beautiful temples funded by the very
rich
and just finally
um I wondered we're talking about a
prime minister and a strong faith and uh
for once I'm not talking about their
Christian faith
um but in the past we've seen Prime
Ministers shy away from talking about
their religion and so do you think we
are seeing something quite unique here
unique up to a point I
I would make a big deal about being a
Hindu he's not that kind of a man as far
as I can tell it will quietly be working
away in his background in terms of what
he thinks is the right thing to do what
his duty is what and I think that's how
it'll work he won't because partly again
as I said Hinduism isn't prescriptive so
it would be quite difficult for him to
then say well Hinduism tells me I need
to do this because it would never do
that so I suspect you'll be working your
way at the background in terms of his
own
conduct the way he behaves and how he
approaches the duties of being a prime
minister
thank you sir
in her column this week Lionel Shriver
says that we've got two used to
emergencies they just never end after
the 2008 crisis she says when interest
rates were to record lows we wrongly
assume that borrowing would stay cheap
forever
how painful will fixing this be Lionel
joins you now alongside the economics
commentator Hamish McRae
Lionel Hamish thank you for joining
spectator TV this week Lionel in your
column this week you write about The
Hangover of economic emergencies tell us
more
um I was warning about the way in which
emergency measures can install
themselves in perpetuity
um
a very good example is zero interest
rates which were brought in in 2008 in a
basically a state of Hysteria and the
understanding was that here we were in
unprecedented times it's interesting how
many how many unprecedented times we've
been in lately that to the point that
we're all sick of the word
um
and it was supposed to
um
get credit moving you know you remember
we used to call it the credit crunch
that's gone by the wayside it sounded
like a candy bar
um
and
it worked after fashion
but very quickly people just started
assuming that money would be free
indefinitely and
um that included government
which meant that
um when covet came along it seemed more
possible
to borrow
hundreds of billions of pounds uh
because it wasn't going to cost much you
know the cost of a candy bar so
um
I'm mourning that uh emergencies in
general
have to
have to be constrained fiercely
constrained and covid regulations are
probably the best
example of an emergency that is
potentially going to be allowed to last
far beyond the real emergency I mean
there are all kinds of ways in which
governments and supernational
organizations like the who are already
gearing up to uh perpetuate at least the
capacity to Institute uh these so-called
measures again you know the
non-pharmaceutical interventions
in in spite of the fact that they didn't
work so uh I find that forbidding and
you know I think
by and large the best parallel is the
way that um emergency legislation is
often misused by authoritarians
um who who have a crisis and the crisis
never ends and they could so the martial
law they they declare temporarily
eventually becomes a standard police
state
and we're not immune to that kind of
slide
hey Miss I'm remember talking about
interest rates
um and when I was talking about there
have we got two years to cheat borrowing
I think that
well let me step back a bit I think I
think long was exactly right that you
get
um an emergency and then you have things
to cope with it and then they become
embedded and actually
the credit crisis and very low interest
is one very good example but there are
lots of others I mean the increase of um
of Taxation and the larger role of the
government uh after Wars uh because
you've increased your taxes to pay for a
war and you and then somehow they've
never come back yeah they never came
back down exactly and you can look at
this you know on the other hand I think
I I would say
[Music]
um
there is slow gradual pushback for
example in the 1970s
um people thought that you could just
keep on inflating the economy and
they'll get into unemployment down it
didn't work inflation shot up but then
it did solve correct uh it was rather
brutally corrected
um through the with the kind of high
interest rates that nobody is trying
right now to bring down inflation and
that is because we are so addicted to
cheap credit that nobody can afford to
pay for the debt they're in so with the
kind of corrective that was used in um
you know Paul volcker's time
interest rates went out up to over 20
percent absolutely anything you don't
know I was very pleased to get a
mortgage at 11 and a half yeah yeah
no look
I think you're right in the sense that
central banks have been extremely
reluctant to push-up rates absolute on
the other hand the markets have been
doing a lot of the dirty work for them
and we've seen that here in the UK where
um the trust came up with a project that
wasn't that wouldn't work and it was the
markets that not only squashed the
project they actually evicted the the
prime minister of the sixth largest uh
economy in the world well what's
mysterious is why the markets didn't do
that a long time ago and why they
haven't done it the United States where
the situation is in my view much worse
well they're doing it you know in house
prices in America are now coming down
sharply because mortgage rates have gone
up so much
um now you know America had I think 22
annual house price inflation on average
or something like that in the big cities
anyway
um but that has now been been pretty
much squashed so I think I think you can
say that I think the markets are very
imperfect they don't have a central mind
but this will stumble around and they do
make Corrections
um out of self-interest out of the ocean
I'm not going to make a moral judgment
yeah yeah no self-interest is one of the
most powerful
social and financial forces in the world
but I suppose in self-interest they're
acting in the interests of Savers yes
and I think what always worries me is
that uh people politicians don't worry
about they worry about borrowers but
they don't worry about Savers nearly
enough and yet we need Savers well
that's been the big moral hazard of this
entire period we have we have robbed
Savers absolutely because they're not
even getting
over inflation or equal inflation way
under inflation they've been getting
nothing so they've been being robbed and
we have given that same money to people
who are in debt and that is wrong and I
think that it's not just wrong in a
moral sense it's also wrong in a
physical sense
actually give a further Twist on that
what's happened is we've created a huge
rise in asset prices which means the
richest people who got the most assets
do you know better towards the most so
we've actually increased
um social inequalities no I agree
this is true we both agreed so we're
gonna have to try and start us up
somehow and levels interesting you
saying
um interest rates uh perhaps need to
rise because we have a situation with
trust economics and I think the same way
we've almost seen this live experiment
where just you know and I think you know
eight weeks ago uh Kate Andrews had a
piece about a guide to what traceanomics
might look like and you had economists
arguing that actually you do need these
uh you know larger interest hikes And
yet when uh you got to the position
where it seemed to be uh that those you
know some trying to push for this it
just met reality and it didn't fly what
did you make of it
well again with the trust thing I
thought what was bizarre about it is
that the markets had not really reacted
that way to say Rishi sunak
spending 400 billion pounds paying
people not to work for a year and a half
and the markets just sat there I find
that mystifying which is why perhaps Liz
trust thought she could just maybe so
there was plenty of precedent
yes I think there was a huge
Collective failure by the central banks
and the financial community of just not
realizing that if you print a lot of
money sooner or later it will show
through in crisis and I think they will
loading I'm sorry to say this but duh I
mean but it just took a long time I mean
when I learned my economics you know I
was told the lags of Economics are very
uncertain can be long I don't think we
thought though that that great flood of
money from 0809 onwards
um would actually take 10 years before
it started yeah I remember uh at the
time puzzling
about why this wasn't resulting in
inflation because it should I had it
explained to me more than once it never
quite computed but it had something to
do with the money staying in the
financial sector in the banking system
certainly in the coveted ERA with all
that overproduction I mean I if I'm not
wrong
within a couple of years uh the Federal
Reserve increased the
money supply of dollars by Third that's
shocking but this was directly to people
so it went into the so-called real
economy and you know big surprise we now
have high inflation and I I think that
there must be a kind of combined effect
of the quantitative easing that has been
going on ever since
2008 and then just this
hyperdrive of trillions of dollars in
pounds uh suddenly it is it's economics
101 that that's going to result in
inflation it's also economics 101 that
it's very hard to bring back down
picking up on your pointer I think is
another element which was which actually
bringing both is the argument which is
that we also had the
um China uh the labor force of China
producing very cheap goods and that held
down
um Goods labor costs true true that and
it was a held down labor cost exactly uh
because you also had Indians you know in
doing selling software so so according
to ukrainians very very good
um selling software services so we did
hold down wages and that that also held
down prices as well so the money hung
around without really going into current
costs they went into asset process
um so if you bought a few bought you
know more or less anything
very well that is a form of inflation
well absolutely right absolutely it's
not in the house the house doubles in
price sure it's still the same body
house oh yeah you know the plumbing
still leaks uh so that's inflation and
the stock market is inflation
no it went through the roof because
there was nowhere else for the money to
go there was no yield anywhere you
couldn't use a savings account even
certificates of deposit weren't paying
anything you couldn't get money anywhere
the only way to preserve your money was
to put it at risk and I that's again
where I I get
you know tiresomely moralistic I I think
I think that is wicked because in order
for ordinary people to preserve their
hard-earned savings they had to risk
losing it
and the more sophisticated they were the
better they did so that if people were
not very sophisticated they they got
they got screwed yeah
and I think that will probably go down
in one of the great sort of social
economic failures
um you know when we get around to
writing economists get around to writing
the economic history books in another uh
10 or 20 years time but I think we can
be
slightly more optimistic now in that
asset prices are falling we've got
um you know we've got a huge bear Market
in bonds as well as inequities and
people don't write about that very much
but uh I saw some data the other day
which was that this is the fourth worst
bond market since 1700 or something like
that so you know not quite as bad as the
as the one after the U.S Civil War but
it's sort of in in that sort of League
game yeah and it's it's odd because as I
understand it bonds and equities are
usually supposed to go and yeah
so I think I think in a way we are
correcting yeah and and I I'm but it's
going to cost a lot of people not all of
them rich
of a big whack of their savings
so Lionel to The Wider Point annual
piece which is about um ultimately how
do we keep emergencies as emergencies uh
rather than you know dragging and
extending what you think the answer is
um I think that we are too adaptable
I think we tend to
um conform to the requirements of the
present
and we're and just therefore assume that
things are going to keep going this way
I I excess excessive adaptation was
copiously on display during covet
because people got used to
of what was truly horrible in short
order
so that
um oh the government has the right to
tell us we can't leave our own house to
tell us that we can't
um exercise our right to free
association we we can't see more than
one friend or we can't see any friend or
only six oh we have to order a
substantial meal with our pint oh no we
can't go to the pub oh what are the
rules this week it was just like and and
even with the total lockdowns
people just started acting as if we'd
always done this we'd never done this
we'd never done this anywhere and
suddenly it was oh another walk down
another lockdown are you kidding me and
I think that this this
is probably a natural human
adaptability which has you know helped
us as a species you can you can be
overly adaptive in politics
and say hold on here
uh I let you do this for a very brief
period of time because
um
I believed you that it was necessary
but you have to keep persuading me it's
still necessary and I'm going to
exercise a great deal of skepticism and
keep an eye out for who's benefiting
from the perpetuation of this emergency
as far as the perpetuation of the zero
interest rates a lot of people were
benefiting from that so the the fed and
the bank of England rapidly got
themselves into a position where they
were going to make a lot of important
people irate if they raised rates
him it's just funny do you agree with
Lionel should be more questioning of
these Trends particularly when they seem
new
so you're right
um
I suppose and I I hope I'm not being
over optimistic but I think we we've
sort of adjusted now to realize I mean
we couldn't they couldn't do lockdowns
again like that I don't know I don't
think I mean I think they were so
frightened they didn't know what they
were doing they stumbled around they'd
never had to cope with anything and
copied everybody else yeah and and the
scientific Community was pretty
unhelpful too because they were all
squabbling with each other and then
trying to you know frighten people even
more by taking extreme positions so I
think science uh you know came badly out
of this even if the other branch of
science uh invented the um the vaccines
with unbelievable speed and I think that
by the way is a very good example of the
way in which the world can pull to get
them
um and government universities big big
Pharma and actually do something that
needed to be done
um so I I take comfort from that
um but but I think that if you look at
China now the struggles it is having and
getting Shanghai to lockdown again the
stories that are privately coming out
from people there who are just you know
totally furious with the regime and the
damage to the regime from all that I I
take a little bit of comfort that people
are common sense prevails and once we
realize that governments are doing
things which are are inappropriate not
so or just plain stupid and then we just
won't let them do it well let me talk
about what we can do I think one of the
important things to do after these
emergencies
is to set the record straight and that's
where I am also encouraged because I
sense especially in relation to covet
and eventually also in relation there's
zero interest rates but certainly with
covet I feel that there is a gradual sea
change going on in the larger public
perception of these non-pharmaceutical
interventions and how effective they
were they weren't
um to the degree to which they were
um politically extreme and
[Music]
and
unpleasant I think we we've gone through
a period that we didn't even want to
think about it because it was so
unpleasant you just like no I don't want
to go back there in my head I don't even
want to think about it let's just go
forward
but
if we are honest about it and look at
the statistics there was no correlation
between the stringency of these
interventions and the medical
consequences there was nothing and
that's all over the world
let's set the record straight that
didn't work and it it also did Untold
damage from which we are still suffering
we will never do that again
thank you Lionel thank you Hamas
the future of feminism journalist Louise
Perry writes belongs to the right
Progressive skills and universities have
turned their back on the traditional
ideas of feminism she thinks but can
conservatives really claimed to
safeguard women's rights the writer
Julie bindle isn't convinced Louise and
Julie joined me now
degrees in this week's magazine you make
the argument that the future of feminism
is conservative
why is that
I mean I think that so this depends on
defining feminism quite a loose way I'm
I'm basically meaning it to use a
political movement that is about
representing women choir women and
women's interests and if we look at it
in that sort of least definition way
then actually the history of feminism
does not necessarily always track
closely with the left by any means you
have you you have periods of time when
conservative more conservative flavors
of feminism are more dominant and so on
until recently I think that the left the
feminism has been very much at home on
the left I think that that is changing
and I think that the big thing that has
changed that is
um what I call the great turf wars which
began in about you know 2010 maybe and
which I think have actually now come to
an end with with the gender critical
side Victorious and I think that one
consequence of of of that decade of of
conflict over um
over transgenderism is that it brought
in a lot of women into feminism who had
not previously been engaged with
feminism and a lot of those women a lot
of those women are mums and a lot of
these women are not off the left and it
has changed the
the political composition of British
feminism and I suspect that's probably
here to stay
Julie what do you make of that I
fundamentally disagree
um I think that there are myths many
women who are single issue campaigners
and absolutely good luck to them respect
to them who are not feminists they are
women's rights activists and again
that's fine who have come into the huge
and extremely important debate about
what is a woman and whether or not male
rapists should be in women's prisons
and they have never campaigned for
example to end male violence as Louise
has they haven't got a grounding in
feminism in other words they can let
things go such as abortion rights they
can ignore the fact that the Tories have
routinely and throughout history
stripped the rights of women prevented
rights from
um prevented women from attaining more
legal rights
taking funding away from domestic
violence refugees attempted to keep
women in the home and out of the
workplace and so I think it's fine if
what you want to fight is the notion of
whether or not a woman can have a penis
because of course they can't
um but it's not all right if you think
about all of the other rights that are
at stake and that the Tories have never
ever
concerned themselves with now that's not
to say that there aren't individual
um decent Tories I've definitely worked
with decent Tories for example in
looking at the harms of the sex trade
and how to regulate
um
the porn industry and they come at this
from pretty much the same position as I
do but if we are to turn to the
conservatives for the rights that we
know that women still do not have pinned
down and still need to establish such as
occasionally convicting the odd rapist
rather than stripping the crown
prosecution service of all its assets
and training then we're not going to get
anywhere I
go to that point
and we're talking about
um I suppose the places you write for
these days and I think to Louise's point
it can feel as though uh you know
left-leading Publications are you know
no longer where you might expect a
feminist to go on some issues but are no
longer such a welcome in place so have
you found that at least when it comes to
some of these views oh Louise is
absolutely right on this uh although I
would take issue with the definition
which is possibly your definition of
Louise's of left-wing press we're
talking about the liberal press and
we're actually talking about one
newspaper and one newspaper only the
guardian so yes what's happened is
cowardice and capitulation and in terms
of the Guardian the capitulation to its
U.S desk and it's the US revenue and
readers because of course they don't
have the turf war in the States because
they don't have a women's movement they
literally have barely any women's
movement that is challenging patriarchy
they just have the lean in feminists in
my view the ones that are concerned with
high salaries at the top of the tree so
who I write for so I write for the mail
on Sunday I write to this potato course
the telegraph I write for the Observer
and I write for other Publications Al
Jazeera across the board and of course
I'm not helping them further their
editorial
um their their editorial position on
immigration or on women's rights in
general I speak a feminism to the
readers to the audience to the listeners
and of course it's important to get the
word out so I'm not a purist I'm far
from abuse I've never been a purist but
I do think that feminism has to be
rooted in a politics that says we have
to take all women with us and that
includes migrant women women of color
women who are on benefits who are single
mothers that the Tories do not generally
care about
okay I mean I I so I think that the
great Synod conservative party in recent
years in terms of its effect on women is
austerity I think that I'm a long way
from forgiving the conservances for that
because obviously stripping the criminal
justice system to the bones stripping
Rape Crisis and other women's services
to the Bone
I think is Dreadful I completely agree
I'm not sure if I would completely buy
the narrative that the conservatives
have always been the anti-feminist party
and labor have always been the
pro-feminist party I think it's more
complicated than that I mean things that
we had coercive control that was
introduced by a conservative government
you know the the the the legislative
record is not always obvious I would say
on that front and I mean my experience
of working with parliamentarians is you
just actually can't really know based on
someone's party affiliation what they're
going to think on something like
prostitution on something like porn
which I think are as fundamental as the
trans issue to the welfare of women
absolutely
um
I think there's a realignment going on
and I don't think it's necessarily
tracking
even talking about left and right in the
old-fashioned ways is slightly unhelpful
because actually we the right are just
as divided as the left the conservative
party Justice divided as the labor party
and I wonder if
if there's an ideological reshuffle
going on
the risk as feminists and I don't
include you in this because you you as
you know we both are working with
parliamentarians and with media Outlets
across the Spectrum but the risk for
some feminists is to say no no we won't
work with anyone who's tainted by
association with the right the left or
our natural home and I say it's the
letter that they've been trying to put
rapists in women's prisons you know this
is the the you you can attempt to frame
that as
you know uh a lapsed moment a moment of
the left forgetting its true principles
or you can say actually are these our
friends is this our is this our natural
home yeah well and of course you're
absolutely right the left well okay
let's distinguish between the feminists
left or feminism that's informed by
anti-hierarchical policies and politics
and that's where I sit I am not involved
in the institutional left I left the
labor party over Jeremy corbyn and I
would do so again and I would certainly
have left over the Kia stama
Ridiculousness over the whole gender
woo-woo and putting women at risk
men on the left
um are sexist
in the main they've never really
embraced feminism the type of feminism
the real feminism that points the finger
at them for their porn use and for their
um lack of respect for women and they
can they can pretend all they like that
they're Progressive but we know that the
slur Turf that many of them use is
actually
just a substitution for another
four-letter word that they'd rather be
calling us that's my view but that
doesn't mean that we can
ignore our leftist principles we have to
challenge those men on the left
and I don't know if I'll ever ever be a
labor party member again I think they're
a disgrace as a party but if you look
then towards the conservatives I do
believe that our wider rights as women
are at risk there's this phrase going
around which is a kind of
justification for working with the
Evangel the the
the religious right-wing which is the
house is on fire and our children are
inside well the house has been on fire
when it comes to violence against women
and children as you know for centuries
and it the house was on fire when
pornography was capturing our boys
and distorting their sexual responses
and their view of women and it was on
fire when it was promoting all kinds of
misogynistic ideology and that's when I
was involved in the women's movement
fighting male violence looking at the
fact that rape has been pretty much
decriminalized the fact that you so
gallantly LED your organization in
bringing about the
end of the rough sex defense and the
like and so I I just think that we have
to recognize that this is a state of
emergency for women it always has been
and we can't possibly just do single
issue politics and look to the gender
nonsense as something that now is a
justification for working with
right-wing evangelists that that
actually wish to strip us of our basic
rights as women there is if we're
sticking with the idea of right when
feminism now
um what are the Hallmarks of it uh in
terms of what uh deficit from I suppose
you know the other stages of this
movement and where is it flourishing is
it you know places like mum's net
yeah mum's net is the heart of this and
uh I my theory is one of the reasons my
mom's vet has uh has has been as
influential as it has it's partly
because it is deliberately geared
towards parents particularly mums but
partly also because of the way it's set
up as a website in that you don't have
you don't have blue ticks you don't
really have like a consistency in
profiles because you just have sort of
mostly nonsense names and you can't just
it functions very differently from
Twitter in that it's a lot more
Anonymous which is the reason why I
think it's the gender critical stuff
sprang up there because it was women who
were scared of otherwise talking about
this in places where they're more easily
identified so anyway so mums that has
been the Vanguard of this and Mom's
there is also by its Nature by Design A
bit chaotic a bit that non-hierarchical
is difficult to organize into a career
movement but I suspect that maybe a
coherent movement is forming out of that
mood
and yeah I mean so I suppose the the way
in which I might distinguish right-wing
feminism from left-wing feminism is that
it's
um one doesn't necessarily associate
with left-wing institutions obviously
but also I think is probably more
more interested in conserving
some institutions and Norms of the past
Danny's a left-wing feminism which is
more about overthrowing everything and
being kind of
um in a state of full Revolution so like
right-wing feminists are more likely to
be
um uh Pro or neutral on marriage for
instance more interested in conserving
the nuclear family all things that have
historically been the targets of
left-wing feminist critique I think the
right and feminists are
and more middle England basically and
more are closer to sort of uh
um the majority of establishment yeah
yeah the majority of people in Britain
are still basically quite traditional
and quite conservative on that sort of
thing but you've got you know obviously
alarm at the at the um
the the turf wars but also on on things
like porn women mothers of Britain are
beside themselves at what is being done
to their children through porn they're
boys and their girls that's one of the
most you look at polling on people's
attitudes towards children being exposed
to porn and is almost unanimous in in
horror if these that's a genuine
feminist issue that's that's something
that feminists have been they have been
talking about ever since the Advent of
the um online porn industry and before
and I actually think it's a good thing
that you've suddenly had the the turf
issue and the internet crucially Because
the Internet allows people to
participate in public life in ways that
are historically more difficult yes
you've had an influx of people who are
maybe single issue but I'm hoping they
don't remain a single issue I'm hoping
that actually there could be a genuine
rallying around other equally important
issues which women feel equally strongly
about
and this could be a real turning point
and actually because the problem we've
always had has been that the left-wing
feminist critique has always been a bit
marginal has always been quite difficult
to hear in the corridors of power
whereas maybe the
the mum's net types
I mean mum's there has always
historically been of great concern to
Prime Ministers and that run up to
elections and yes and and I'm very
anti-elitist when it comes to feminism
I've never been a theoretical feminist
in that sense and I've never relied on
I mean academic feminism is by and large
a disgrace and I think we could probably
agree on that my I can say I mean I'm a
lesbian just in case your viewers didn't
realize and um and I've you know long
campaigned for the rights of women's
sexual autonomy and what worries me
about some of the discourse with the
kind of trans debate
and you know me I am absolutely full
throttle against any of this gender
identity nonsense
but what worries me is when feminists
talk about sex stereotypes harmful sex
stereotypes that's what we mean by
gender the imposition of gender and it
worries me if the right Wingers get hold
of this which they have they're going to
be against any quote unquote gender
non-conformity and that would include
lesbians and that might include gay men
and that might include kids that just
don't want to actually grow up in the
stereotypical sense whether they're
lesbian or gay or just non-conforming
and so that's why I think we need to
have a really close look at the aims and
objectives and the end goal of right
Wingers when they join us in this fight
to end gender nonsense but in conclusion
a middle England feminist movement we
won't call it right-wing conservatism is
something you could get behind you look
I support women fighting for rights for
themselves and for their children and I
absolutely support the
popularity and increasing popularity of
issues that are of concern to women I
don't want to give any ammunition to the
right so that our hard-wom rights are
removed or under threat and we've seen
that happen with Roe versus Wade in the
U.S and we can't say things like
whatever you think about abortion it
doesn't matter the house is on fire it
does matter because of course abortion
is crucial it's a crucial aspect of
women's control over our own bodies and
our reproductive systems and that is
should be at the Bedrock of concerns
about feminism so yes absolutely with
Louise that we have to popularize
women's rights and the fight for women's
rights but to not give any ammunition to
the right thank you Julie thank you
Julius
and finally the spectator's diary editor
James Hill has been busy this summer
writing a biography of Liz truss now a
political obituary to explain the horror
of writing about the former prime
minister's rather short Premiership he
joins me now
James thanks for joining spectator TV
today you've read an article about Liz
truss for this week's magazine but it's
more about your experience of writing
about this truss
you signed up along with Harry Cole to
do a memoir which initially did you
imagine would be spanning all these Mark
in the beginning of a long Premiership
yes well I mean I think like a lot of
Tory MPS Casey we thought when we
started the book it would be two years
until the next election two years of Liz
truss as prime minister and so we were
hoping to go up to the Party Conference
on 5th of October and then really end it
on that note has sort of addressed the
nation the first time really introducing
herself and we quickly realized within a
matter of well quite literally three
days when her majesty died it was gonna
be a very different book
and you quickly became a meme can you
tell us about this uh effectively when
it seemed as though Liz truss's
Premiership might not be so long lasting
and lots of people started to make fun
of your book yeah
um it was quite a surreal experience I
have to say
um I think it was probably around the
time of the mini budget and thereafter
the week thereafter really and it was
clear that it wasn't going as as planned
um and then around that sort of
conference time uh when that was it
started it and um as it became clear her
Premiership was not going to survive
both in terms of its radical Mission but
also herself personal survival uh it was
around the point that um have
penultimate fortnite and power that the
meme started saying you know if you're
having a bad day at work the Chinook
James heal uh and Carrie Cole who've got
a book out of distrust of his rights to
power knocked you out till Christmas and
you got some quite good publicity from
this in the sense that yes you were
becoming a subject of mockery but thank
you
you'll have the last laugh James when
you're best-selling uh you know author
um but ultimately had a private eye uh
talking about you know what will last
longer Liz truss uh you know or you know
with a book you know with a book come
out after she is done or so forth and
then he also had kissed armor pick up
the mantle and bring up a prime
minister's questions
um have you been waking up in recent
weeks just in the middle of the night
worrying and hoping this trust will last
a bit longer for your book deadline it's
a very surreal thing and I have to say
yeah kissed armor will have earned his
free copy uh we'll check that in the
register of interest
um and uh it was it was it was it was it
was a bizarre time to when you get your
phone buzzing uh to talk people
mentioning from school getting in touch
saying you do realize you're being you
know mocked by the by the lead of the
opposition
um it's a weird one as a journalist and
I'm sure you know you can relate to this
which is that on the one hand you're you
know the people involved often you
sometimes you know them socially uh
professionally but equally you you try
and keep a degree of of Detachment
particularly when you're writing about
someone who's involved in such major
decisions that she was at the time
um so it was it was a surreal mix of
trying to
um some days just embracing the chaos
and other days thinking well God will
hope it lines up with our publication
schedules as it did it did almost
perfectly and that we had to literally
submit it today and she obviously went
uh on Monday but uh so you've had a
front row seat in the short Premiership
that is Liz trusses and that involved as
you did he heard on your article uh
ultimately going to achieving for I
think two sit-downs and you're also
spoken to lots of her aides when you
began it because you say you thought
this is the beginning of probably two
years into an election and as we've
documented in The Spectator there is you
know plenty of a sense that made Power
trips too far but they were going to
have to you know come in strong banish
various figures to political Siberia
what do you take away in terms of what
you learned from having this front row
seat when it comes to what went wrong
for Liz truss
um I mean hubris was the word used to be
by one of her aides uh but also I mean
just to reflect obviously we spent most
of the book um in August writing about
her rise and so what was really
interesting arguably her rise over the
last five years from Chief Secretary of
Treasury to trade to foreign office in
some ways perhaps the patterns that she
had the methods and the traits that she
exhibited which made her quite good at
that as a sort of mid-ranking cabinet
minister maybe weren't so suited for the
Premiership so I actually read a lot of
your articles and your interviews are
chronicling the trust years and I think
that what really stood out to me was
along with the mistakes that were made
during that kind of three-week
transition period before the Premiership
which I think baked in a lot of the
cabinet changes and policy changes was
also just the sense that I still think
that the the top job the Premiership is
still a step up and I think that often
you have ministers who you know a very
are able in certain roles but then you
put on the microscope in that post and
suddenly it's a whole different game
just like Gordon Brown had he was known
as the submarine chances that come up
three times a year but there's number 10
he was very different from number 11.
and what will you be getting your mother
for Christmas this year
I think she's had enough about Liz trust
to love her last time so maybe a Rishi
seen that book perhaps okay but you're
not volunteering to write that one just
yet not yet given we've now got the
political reverse minus touch I think
anyone we now write about will have a
political death so I'm not sure we're
going into any of that and James is
finally do you want to plug your book
when when can viewers who have been
tempted by this conversation and buy it
uh you can buy it online from next week
and the physical copy comes out next
month okay thank you James for joining
us today
that's it for this week once again don't
forget to subscribe to the spectator's
YouTube channel just click the Subscribe
button at the bottom of the screen and
tap the Bell icon so you never miss an
episode
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]